La volta al món a peu, dia 254.
Nit, totalment sense cap incident.
L'únic que diré és que les cases aquestes on jo pensava que no hi havia ningú, sí.
Viu gent perquè heu de veure un home i una dona.
Però em sembla que no m'han ni vist perquè ni tan sols m'han fet cap gest.
Bueno, tu.
Avui, pujar, pujar, pujar, pujar.
Serà un dia dur, eh?
Serà un dia dur.
Doncs he arribat a la primera vila.
Veig que la Neuropea també està aquí pagant carreteres, eh?
Ostres, tu, això està molt lluny d'Europa, eh?
Bueno, salam.
Aquí hi ha un supermercat.
Suposo que oblidem-nos de bars.
Però com a mínim, bueno, espero que em deixin carregar la bateria.
I aprofito per pujar el vídeo, que ahir no el vaig pujar.
I aquí tinc bona cobertura inesperadament.
Tot carregat, tot pujat.
Perfecte. Mira, un gos.
Raro aquí veure gossos.
Avui és dilluns, dia 10 d'agost de 2026.
No m'estranya que faci calor, perquè això de la calor és de 10 d'agost.
És l'època més calorosa de l'any, potser.
El pla és el següent.
Primer de tot, arribar a Artuig, l'últim poble d'aquesta vall,
que està a 9 km i 900 metres, no, 400 metres de desnivell positiu.
Pujareta, en principi, amb una carretera o pista així.
Després d'Artuig, allà hauré de comprar provisions,
perquè no trobaré més pobles fins... bé, més endavant.
I pujaré fins als Llacs, que no recordo el nom.
Hi ha diversos.
La meva idea és pujar fins al que està més a dalt de tot i acampar allà.
Ja ho veurem.
Si faig això, serien 14 km extra, després d'Artuig,
i 1.200 metres de desnivell positiu.
Pujareta interessant.
Allà acamparia, i el dia següent intentaria l'ascens a Alaudín Pas.
Alaudín Pas és un coi de muntanya que es troba als 3.800 i pico metres
sobre el nivell del mar.
Tela marinera.
De fet, on acamparia avui serien pels 3.000 metres.
Llavors, demà, primera hora, seria l'ascens al coi,
i després la baixada,
els Llacs de l'Audín,
que també són molt macos, igual que els Llacs d'avui,
però els de demà encara més.
Bueno, demà, si aconsegueixo, eh?
Hi ha la possibilitat de fer el Pic de l'Audín.
No sabia si dir-ho o no, perquè si després no ho faig és com un fail.
Potser no el faig, perquè no sé si és fàcil, difícil,
no sé com es traurà demà el temps,
no sé com es traurà de forces, d'aigua...
A veure si farà molt de vent, ja ho veurem.
El Pic de l'Audín són 4.100 metres de desnivell positiu.
O sigui, és un 4.000.
Poca broma, vale?
Però bueno, de moment, primera tirada fins a Artuch.
Bueno, tu no caminant ni un moment,
i ja hi ha aquí una espècie de museu.
Diu que és el complex de Panjurt.
Veig una mesquita allà.
Bueno, ja que estem aquí, anem a veure-ho.
Val, ja he descobert què és això.
És el mausoleu d'en Rudaki.
Un senyor, el pare de la poesia en persa.
Us vaig explicar l'altre dia que
Tadjikistan estava...
Bueno, és el mateix idioma que l'Iran,
que el farsi, que el persa.
S'escriu diferent, però és el mateix idioma.
I, bueno, la primera persona que va escriure poesia en vers
en persa, doncs era aquest senyor d'aquí.
I aquest era el seu mausoleu.
Però no sé si està obert.
Està tancat, però aquest senyor té les claus.
Menys mal. No sóc l'únic turista.
Veig que ja hi ha quatre persones més.
I aquesta vall té ja un munt de cases, eh?
I ja grans. Crec que hi ha algun hotel i tal.
Vale.
Bueno.
Bueno, no té gaire valor artístic, diria.
Però suposo que pels perses i tal
deu tenir un valor simbòlic.
Hi ha un museu.
Crec que passo, perquè literatura persa,
com podeu comprendre.
No és el meu subjecte de més interès.
Rahmat.
Pujada sostinguda.
He netejat els mitjons
i la samarreta.
I, error, m'he mullat
el barret pensant que estaria més fresc.
I sí, estic més fresc, però clar,
es queda així.
I és horrible perquè no veig res.
I és molt incòmode.
He d'esperar a que s'assequi, tu.
Hola, què tal?
He arribat a Artuch.
Bueno, al Mapi marca que hi ha un market,
un supermercat.
Però el mapa diu que...
I he preguntat a uns locals d'aquí darrere
i m'han dit que sí que sí.
Primer he trobat uns russos que anaven a fer un altre pic.
Un altre pic, vull dir un altre lloc.
No sé què anaven a fer.
I m'han dit que si pregunto als locals
potser puc dinar a casa seva
pagant.
Home, això estaria bastant bé.
Tinc bastanta gana.
Allò sembla una mesquita, no?
No ho sé.
Són molt diferents les mesquites d'aquí
que les de Turquia.
I el market diu
que hauria d'estar allà.
I jo no veig absolutament res.
Doncs està tancat el supermercat.
Aquest no sé si està fent alguna trucada
per preguntar si l'obren.
Estic fotut, eh?
Sense supermercat.
Sí, bastant, bastant.
Falta provisió per promenar, però bueno.
Bueno, l'hove al supermercat,
no sé com ha quedat,
però l'he dit, ostres, i puc dinar.
I li dic, previ, ho pago.
I li diu, sí, ja ho tinc aquí, eh?
I diu, sí, sí, endavant, endavant.
S'ha posat molt simpàtic. És una gresca, us ha fet.
I sí, sí, m'han portat pa.
Té blau, diuen.
Bueno, ara veurem de quin color és.
L'amanida que porto menjant aquesta
amanida des d'Albanya, jo crec.
L'amanida amb tomàquet i...
I que m'encanta, eh? Però
trobo que és molt curiós que
des d'Albanya, Grècia, Turquia,
Georgia, Uzbekistan i ara
Tajikistan tinguin la mateixa amanida.
I el plof, que crec que
serà una constant. Però bueno, ja m'agrada, eh?
En aquesta sala
tan curiosa, plena de catifes
i, bueno, això és el típic lloc de menjar
pels tajiks, eh?
I aquí fotos de la graduació
del germà del noi amb el que
he parlat ara.
Molt bé, tu, genial. Estic molt content.
No m'han deixat pagar.
No ho entenc.
És una guesca, oi? Home.
Pago i em diu
no, no, no, no. Hòstia.
Molt heavy, tio.
Molt fort, em sembla. Genial, eh?
Genial. Però...
Ostres, tu. M'he ofert, eh?
Però m'han dit no, no, no, ja està.
M'han ficat la sala per mi sol. M'han deixat
carregar la bateria. Impressionant, Tajikistan.
Impressionant. El market no està
obert, però he agafat el pa
que m'han donat i no me l'he menjat. Me l'he guardat
i tinc una mica més de pa, per tant, només tinc full pa.
I el noi m'ha dit que
els jacs de l'Audin, que estan
a l'altra banda del pas, és a dir,
en principi demà, hi ha una cafeteria
o algo. Bueno, cafeteria aquí
ja veurem com és, eh? Però hi ha algo, val?
Llavors, allà, doncs podré comprar.
I a més, el dia de demà, cap al final
del dia, si camino ben bastant,
doncs també arribo a un poble i en principi
em podré revestir, per tant,
ok, no necessito menjar.
La part dolenta és que
estic sentint que trona a l'altre
banda d'aquestes muntanyes. Espero que no m'enxampi.
Com he dit abans, ara són
12 o 14 quilòmetres cap
allà, depèn d'on vulgui acabar acampant,
amb uns 1.200-1.400 de descendent
positiu. Not bad.
Plou.
Ja avisava la previsió que fins a les
quatre podia ploure.
A veure si es queda així com ahir, que també hi ha quatre
gotes. I no va anar
més. O m'he de parar,
posar l'impermeable i tot plegat.
Hello!
Enric, and you?
Es ja.
Nice to meet you, es ja. Hello.
Bye bye.
Bueno, hi ha més nens
que adults en aquest país,
n'estic convençut, és que surten de sota
les pedres, tu. Bueno.
Hello.
Què anava a dir?
Vale, aquí
la vall es divideix en dos.
Puc anar cap a la dreta o cap a l'esquerra.
El meu camí és
cap a l'esquerra. I de moment
aguanta. Mentida.
Anem cap a la dreta, no anem cap a l'esquerra.
I d'acord balcony.
Eh?
Heu dit eli rescued?
Sí.
Primer és que hi oglines
un al
ja fa una estona que la pista s'ha acabat
aquí ja no hi ha més cotxes, alguns burros he vist
i envoltat d'aquestes muntanyes
brutals
a aquestes parets
que ara cauen quatre gotes
des de fa estona, però bueno
segueix així
i bueno tu, molt guapo eh
ara m'he trobat tres grups de turistes
tres grups de dos
que venien dels jacs on vaig jo
i m'han dit que és guapíssim
m'han dit vols que t'ensenyi fotos
i jo no, no, no, no vull espòilers
són les quatre de la tarda
i queden uns quatre quilòmetres
i cinc-cents cinquanta metres
de desnei positiu
que té pinta que serà
així
presos
ASE
a
Res
A
Fins demà!
M'ha costat d'identificar, eh?
Però aquest que és molt punxegut del mig
és l'aidun,
el que hauria de pujar demà.
Ho veig massa punxegut, això.
Demà veurem, eh?
Però ho veig massa tècnic.
Després hi ha dos passos, el meu,
que està darrere, no s'acaba de veure,
i el pas de l'andant, crec que es diu,
que és el de la banda esquerra,
que es veu que és bastant més fàcil.
Però, bueno,
si vaig pel meu pas,
el meu pas, el pas de l'aidun,
podré veure un llac extra,
que si vaig per l'altre pas no puc.
I, bueno, demà diuen que farà bon temps.
Bueno, aquí hi ha uns turistes.
Saludarem.
Hello!
Russos, probablement.
Avui és espectacular, eh?
Espectacular.
Bueno, són les 6. He pujat bastant lent perquè
m'he parat bastant
i també perquè la pujada tenia
bastanta tela, eh?
Queda una hora i pico de sol.
Arribaré al llac superior
o em quedaré aquí?
Aquí a baix, que encara no els hem vist.
Aquí a baix n'hi ha dos, anem a veure'ls.
Vale, amb aquest llac no hi comptava, eh?
Perquè el mapi el marcava com a aiguamoll.
Però no, no, d'aiguamoll res, tu.
És un llac, bueno, estany, com li vulguis dir.
És que cap allà, cap allà, la...
el color és molt blau, eh?
Fuà, quina passada.
Vau,.....
Hi heu de sortir, per això.
Escolteu-me.
Qui els vai Noticear?
Si no hi ha algú, L'E대 i els pares,
segurament heu de pocar-se d' vagiar alol.
Estevent hopava que si som aquí,
s'ha Baba a poc, oi?
hmmm aquí.
Uau, hòstia, tenen la música. Uau, que increïble. Brutal.
Aquest no és el llac on tenia previst acampar. El que tenia previst acampar està cap allà.
Veieu que hi ha una paret enorme i una glacera? Doncs sota hi ha un llac.
El problema, em diuen que vagi. Ok, one second.
O sigui, el tema és que queda poc de sol i aquell lloc està...
Bueno, té una muntanya davant, llavors li donarà l'ombra.
I bueno, aquests pocs moments que em queden ara no els acabaria de gaudir, potser.
I el llac potser té millors vistes demà, si li pillo que li dóna el sol.
Però bueno, també demà estaria més a prop del pas, sí que en polla.
I aquí, en aquest llac, potser hi ha una mica de harana.
Aquell lloc ja han posat música. Ara ja han deixat.
Bueno, baixo a mirar i m'ho penso.
Bueno, doncs he vingut amb aquesta gent i evidentment m'han donat menjar.
M'han donat plof una altra vegada i amanida.
I la beguda aquesta que vaig menjar ahir, que era com un iogurt.
I bueno, molt simpàtics, la cosa es comença a animar.
Treuen el vodka, m'ensenyen com es brinda en Tajik.
I quan les coses comença a animar comença a ploure, tu.
Tampoc és la pluja del segle, però bueno.
Ara estic aquí sota l'arbre, ells estan allà, són uns 8.
Quan acabi de ploure, normalment aquests dies, o sigui avui, està plovent, jo què sé, 20 minuts i després para.
Doncs res, m'esperaré aquí sota l'arbre i després aniré a campar a l'altra banda del llac, perquè aquí no hi ha lloc i a més tampoc.
Vull jarar, no és del tot la nit a més.
Soc super mega pixapí perquè estava parlant amb aquesta gent preguntant-li si el pic aquest és difícil.
Crec que em diuen que és fàcil, però bueno.
I de cop i volta apareix l'arc de Sant Martí aquí darrere complet, eh?
Arc de Sant Martí complet de punta a punta.
I faig, oh!
I arriben de mi, bàsicament.
Els hi ha sigut igual.
Home, però és que és molt maco, tu.
És espectacular, increïble.
Millor final del dia impossible.
El creuament de riu més delicat del dia i potser de tota la volta al món a peu.
Sense bastons.
Una mica complicadet, m'han dit.
Bueno, és que per flipar, i no sé si em sentiu bé perquè hi ha bastant de soroll, però per flipar aquí hi ha com un restaurant, tu.
Hi havia una gent occidental, no sé d'on eren, sopant.
Estem a gairebé 3.000 metres.
I els he preguntat si es podia passar i em diuen que per aquestes roques, bueno.
Delicadet, vinga.
No hauria d'estar amb el mòbil a la mà.
A veure aquesta pedra.
Una, dos, tres, oh!
Val, és.
S'aguanta, s'aguanta, vinga.
Vinga.
Següent, fàcil.
Vale, ara cap allà.
Tampoc hauria de ser problema.
Opala, vinga.
Última pedra delicada, bé.
Bé, no està lluny, vale.
M'ho feia amb un got d'aigua, eh.
Doncs sí, tu, estem, diria que als 1.900, ara després us ho diré.
Hi ha un restaurant aquí, tu.
Bé, encara es veu el sol.
Brutal, he fet bé a no anar a l'altre llac, eh.
Aquest molt a més.
Bueno, no l'he vist l'altre, però aquest.
Té aquí la posta de sol.
No he pogut gravar els homes aquells perquè els he preguntat.
Ei, em sap greu si gravo quan han tret el vodka, saps?
Em diuen, millor no, millor no.
Els he respectat.
S'escolta?
Els tios d'abans tenien una altaveu i suposo que tenien un micròfon.
No sé què estan fent, si estan rasant o estan cantant.
Bueno, jo ja perdo una mica la noció de les acampades que he fet,
ja em desubico, però diria que aquesta és la més èpica
o de les més èpiques que he fet mai.
O sigui, he vist glaceres, he vist muntanyes, he vist parets així,
però no sé si l'hi havia vist mai.
Una glacera i una paret d'aquestes reflectides o reflexades a un llac,
un llac tan en calma, zero vent.
Ara s'ha anat el sol ja.
I bueno, tot aquest prat, no sé, brutal.
Un lloc increïble, Epicardo.
He vist que t'aixequis tant tu.
Ha costat arribar fins aquí, eh?
Avui, 30, 30, bueno, 29 quilòmetres
i 1.700 i pico de desnivell positiu.
No ha sigut fàcil.
Han sigut diversos dies de caminar per carretera.
Però ha valgut la pena, tu.
Demà tenim un dia així molt guapo, també,
però l'acampada no serà tan èpica com avui.
Si tingués més provisions, no, tampoc.
Si tingués més provisions em quedaria per aquí, faria algun pic, potser.
Visitaria algun llac, tornaria a acampar aquí.
Però bueno, tinc una mica de pressa, com ja sabeu, per arribar a la Xina.
I ja està.
Bueno, ja tinc un restaurant.
Vull dir que em podria quedar el que volgués, realment.
Surrealista.
Estem als...
Ho posaré aquí.
No arriba als 3.000 metres, però gairebé.
L'airet que passa, com passa airet, és fred.
D'acord?
Però no és...
No fa fred.
O sigui, fred no fa.
Cosa que, bueno, jo crec que els 3.000 metres a l'agost
una mica més de fred sí que podria fer.
Jo hi ha dies que he passat fred.
Acampant.
No sé si mai he acampat tan alt, ara que hi penso.
Hauria de fer memòria.
Diria que mai he acampat tan alt.
Bueno, tu...
Ha sigut un dia molt maco.
Paisatge espectacular.
No sé si em quedo amb aquest paisatge d'avui
o amb el de Georgia d'aquell dia tan fatídic
que em van haver de portar en cotxe.
Jo diria que amb el d'avui, eh?
Però no posaré el mal foc, tampoc.
És que, clar, glaceres nosaltres a Catalunya no estem acostumats a veure.
Bueno, és que m'estic girant tota l'estona, però...
No és tan habitual, llavors.
M'emociono.
I l'art de Sant Martí, tu.
Molt bé, senyors.
No sé com veureu aquest vídeo.
Si el veieu el dia 11, per vosaltres el dia 12 és l'eclipsi.
Aquí no hi ha eclipsi.
Aquí no hi ha eclipsi perquè, bueno, és de nit.
De fet, és de nit a la hora que a Catalunya és l'eclipsi.
Aquí és de nit, crec.
I no hi haurà eclipsi ni res.
Ja miraré les fotos de les xarxes socials.
Segur que hi ha un munt de recopilacions, vídeos, tal...
És la típica cosa que a mi em fa il·lusió veure.
Jo soc el típic que canyiria.
De fet, la meva idea era anar als ports i acampar allà, fer un bivac i el que sigui, saps?
Però bueno, gaudiu-lo amb protecció, sobretot.
No el mireu amb u i nu.
Perquè us pot...
Bueno, es pot fer danys permanents a la retina.
Ja estan sortint històries de gent que a l'anterior eclipsi de l'any 80, no sé què,
van mirar els ulls directament a l'eclipsi i es van quedar, no secs, però van tenir mal permanent.
Per tant, no jugueu amb això.
Mireu amb les ulleres o, bueno, gaudiu simplement de quan es faci fosc.
Ja està.
Bona nit.